t'étrangler ses bons amis des images
qu'on n'a pas oublié une arrestation
musclée
c'était en octobre 2012 souvenez-vous la
policière à l'oeuvre c'est stéphanie
trudeau matricule 7,8 normand grondait
elle réplique
elle donne sa version dans un livre où
est tout à fait servir et se faire salir
mon histoire est un titre un peu
coup-de-poing ça va à peu près dans le
même sens de tout livre madame trudeau
exprime surtout le fait qu'elle n'a
aucun regret des heureux des événements
qui ont survécu keith ont survécu sont
survenus pardon l'événement bien sûr
durant le printemps arabe où elle espère
jets de poivre cayenne des manifestants
aucun régate côté la dic c'était une
émeute qui était justifiable et leur
ferait la même chose
aucun regret non plus pour les
événements sur la rue papineau où elle a
arrêté trois hommes dans les conditions
qu'on connaît bien le son seul regret
les les propos qu'elle a tenus qui ont
été enregistrés malgré elle dans le
véhicule de police
je vous cite je voulais c'est ptet elle
disait en guise d'excusé j'avais les
émotions à fleur de peau l'intimidation
véhicules à l'intérieur comme à
l'extérieur de mon service les menaces
les frustrations et les humiliations de
tous gens sont sortis d'un seul coup et
je sais que ce n'était pas beau à
entendre
qu'est ce qu'elle avait dit exactement
dans le bourg rappelez-nous l'on a les
excuses mais elle s'était elle était en
colère s'est accaparé de gratuite
guitare et web
c'est une conversation pour une dizaine
de minutes où elle tenait des propos
assez durs paie parfois injurieux à
l'égard des personnes qu'elle avait
arrêté et décarie rouge en général à
cette époque-là très bien par ailleurs
et règle ses comptes avec les médias
ses patrons et son syndicat oui elle et
elle tient des propos très durs envers
son syndicat et ses patrons qu'elle
accuse de ne pas l'avoir défendu tout au
long de cette histoire et joue encore je
vous donne la station elle est faite
sous forme d'ironie mais écoutez la l
attaque directement à ses patrons elle
dit merci de nous avoir défendu et
soutenu sur la place publique comme
c'était votre devoir de le faire on est
trahi que par les siens
vous m'avez fait détester une des choses
que j'aimais le plus au monde être en
uniforme et à être au service des autres
vous voyez c'est assez dur mais voilà
livre publié par matricule salut et
merci normand au plaisir